[Music]
Samuel leaves here and this week winners
on a Wednesday with sat with Brett
Jackson Brett welcome to the show hello
welcome
you've just been best not backstage what
am I talking about but in our offices
yes
which I guess quite a bit backstage
right now meeting all our wonderful
Stanley and I are rock star staff indeed
and also some of our advanced students
that are here using our offices to tell
us a little about yourself
so my name's rich Jackson as someone
once said been in business for about
eight years now from Barnsley I'm the
watering in part of and watering in
wedding jewel
run a tipi business run a business that
works in primary schools and then after
following yourself etc investing in
property I love just become financially
fringe oh that's awesome
and you messaged me on Facebook yes
literally was it like three to three
days ago that - two days ago and you
messaged me and said I'm financially
free you can add me to your list yeah I
don't know I was just like man I've got
to interview someone now every single
week on the winners on the Wednesday and
not only if they got to be financially
for at least successful in some way but
they've also got to be willing to be on
camera yeah so thank you so much for
coming down what has been your strategy
then - it to hit finance I'm so far what
I've done we are the businesses with a
profit have just invested in just nice
and simple resi vitae let's yeah I've
not done anything crazy yet just took me
like crazy you mean that sort of thing I
mean a few few people they're feeling me
estate agent friends that's trying to
get me to a developer summit into a
10-10 flat apartment that sort of thing
so we're doing rolling down the line I
could do but in the minute I've just
been doing normal residential vital it
so you've been doing that just basic
single that's not crazy stuff like HMOs
well flipster just run-of-the-mill
single buy-to-let yeah and 25% down some
20% down I have just refinanced as well
so my properties are going up in buying
refine and
aurelio you're getting high I mean we
talked about you came to the crash
course the back end of last year yes
yeah it's December 2017 so it's almost
been a year now yeah just shy of a year
let me ask you Kristin when you came to
the crash course what happened
well you just learn so much and anyone
who was thinking about it I definitely
recommend going on it yeah it's free so
it's like and you haven't done any
advanced training no you've literally
and here's the funny thing like those
people say like all Samuel just trying
to get money half people just like 99%
of my students only do free stuff like
you what what free stuff have you
watched are you to a video yeah read
your book obviously you pay for shipping
costs and shortcuts your mom would hate
to say come to the crash course with
crash cars obviously follow the grill so
literally literally and I'm not
suggesting that people do this but
literally you haven't paid any obviously
your times valuable yeah you took a lot
of time reading the book and saw that
but I I haven't received any money from
you and and and and and yet you've used
and applied what you've learned on the
free crash course and the free books and
stuff which is just fantastic yeah
perfect absolutely fantastic and I'm so
I'm so pleased for you so tell me about
the climate properties that you're
buying and what kind of return on
investment you go so like say I've got a
range from 50 to 85 thousand properties
not that many people comment it's all
right
the range is from 50,000 to 85,000 okay
I've got nine properties yeah which
makes about just shy of three grand a
month which is the average salary
I choose average salary exactly the
average I think the average salary is
about two and a half thousand a month
well yeah so you know sorry so you just
you just probably just over the average
salary just over the average and that's
passive income passive income for
example me 50,000 hours cost just over
ten yeah and deposit fees just over I
make five fifty a month I think my
mommy's just over hundred that's crazy
your mom's diamond just over sixteen or
something yeah the biggest one which is
83 thousand it is a far bed really nice
town house and I get five nine five a
month for that so what you're doing then
is you're behind properties that are
near where you actually lift yeah that
which is where bonsly bonsly bonsly near
Barnsley and you'll find them for around
about 50 60 70 80 grand
yeah you rent them out for like four
fifty five fifty that one a price you
making a twenty five percent return yeah
and then of them and then you're getting
paid want in return on investment which
is cash flow yeah which is not mega but
we ain't nine properties you got nine
properties 988 it's enough for an
average income so technically
financially free air but you're also
getting paying the capital depreciation
which doesn't pay the bills but you've
said that they've gone up a bit yeah
just we find out refinance getting about
15 grand out or one of them so well
somewhat on another house brilliant so
talk to me about being a landlord then
talk to me about
has that been challenging yeah I mean
everything has its ups and downs
you'll know yourself run into business
people look at you look at me look at
people doing business and yeah oh it's
alright for them but I don't see you're
working late at night don't see dupes
and downs Excel yeah sure don't go wrong
about now percent of my tenants arson
yeah I've had some tenants where but
again this is my father didn't owe me
due diligence
rush to get someone in no rent trash
doubts topics any problems to get them
out it's enough to scare some people
it's partly again yeah I've known it
since obviously except them
you've learned from it learn from they
have probably attended my advanced
training which you were too tight to
sign up for you to probably not have
that problem I'm kidding no money
together yeah I'm sure so so do you
manage your properties yourself I do but
it's getting to that stage now like some
remover businesses I'm gonna down the
line obviously look at how much time do
you spend managing your property
portfolio not that much and like I said
less than an hour a week yeah okay so
you imagine yourself which means that
you're some people love being where
you're at because in one sense it's the
sweet spot yeah because you've got nine
properties which is not loads
you manage them yourself and with HMO
you could have nine tenants in one HMO
yeah which would be just as difficult to
manage in fact probably even harder
because in HMOs people are moving in and
out all the time but in single let's
some of moistening well let's about the
same tenant for like seven years I said
so as long as you get a good tenant and
I really believe that a bad tenant is
worse than no tenant as you've done good
tenant and you can literally just keep
an eye on make sure they're okay but
it's very very happening some of our
houses and they're absolutely immaculate
yeah
I believe they're definitely moved from
my house and live in that house yeah
yeah so you feel like you're at the
sweet spot because you're saving a lot
of money by managing it yourself
yeah but managing it yourself he's only
taking you like an hour a week yes you
get the phone call boilers yeah stopped
all you gotta do is ring the plumber
yeah put them all together and then yeah
how you're a businessman or an
entrepreneur
yeah so house have you systemized it at
all or do you if someone what would
happen if someone had a problem on
Christmas Eve like is that something
that would be a problem
well the Elvis wood bears on the problem
and I am I'm always open for business to
be fair yeah you'll know yourself been
an entrepreneur the phone rings you
gonna answer it
Wow well yeah fair enough it is one of
them I think down the line I own but
obviously sure but at the end of the day
you're doing about an hour a week on it
you're making three grand a month on it
and it's the core portfolio is rising
yeah going wrong down the line when
there's more about properties more and
more potential problems yeah I run my
own business is any way I'll not want to
Y actually getting that phone call
learned a lot money in what are you glad
that you have started off managing them
yourself yeah definitely I think I do if
you were just getting started I
definitely recommend the first one off
to try it self-knowledge even if it's
just six months because you'll learn so
much doing the DPS how to rank guide
this obviously you got to educate
yourself get the right contracts but the
thing is
being a landlord you can learn all that
stuff for free online oh yeah like being
a landlord IEP see what insurance is do
you need all that kind of stuff
you can learn that for free online right
yeah now the stuff that I teach which is
which you've experienced somewhat on the
crash course and my book and the YouTube
videos is about wealth creation and
about how to buy properties you've no
money down about how to get really high
returns how if you type in Google how to
find my investment patch or where's a
good place to invest right now you can
have so many idiots give it all kinds of
all right or if you said how can i you
know how can i buy a house with no money
again you can have a little bit it's you
can't do it and all that that's the
stuff I teach yeah the hard stuff the
stuff that's gonna make you wealthy but
the actual management of it if I taught
that stuff people wouldn't pay me money
because you can get it for free like
they're finding that sweet spot an area
depending where you're from it's
definitely worth going on the cards
they're worth paying because all you
need is that one out in that sweet spot
yeah that's paid for oh you've got your
sweet spot
keeping best exactly talk to me a little
bit about what you think is gonna happen
what's going on in Barnsley and jemmye
up north with the property market well
property expert yeah double dual this
invest bonsly and it's getting loads of
money spent in it they're doing all the
town up the surrounding areas Robin's
game only spent Doncaster yeah and
there's a lot of work opportunities out
there there's a lot of need because
we've got a lot of obviously industrial
factories yeah steel work Sheffield etc
and there's just so much opportunity
yeah ready for the taking what do you
think of people that say because I
strongly disagree but lifting are your
thoughts that people decide if you buy
50 60 70 80 Brother house OHE house yeah
thanks eights cheap because if they live
in London or whatever they're like
thinking that's a really cheap house
those type of houses are dog kennels and
awful houses in awful neighborhoods with
awful people and if you buy a cheap
house
you're just gonna get really bad tenant
what do you think about someone that
lives in Barnsley I totally disagree
some of the houses out bar 50,000 I'm
going to see a flat tomorrow at 40,000
yeah immaculate look in the area and
close to town center yeah people can't
people can't get their head around that
yeah people think that because it's a
cheap house it must be a sketchy area
now don't get me wrong sometimes it can
be oh yeah but some of these bug like
bonsly is a very cheap area to buy a
house it but it doesn't mean that
everyone really lives in Barnsley is
Scott oh no it just so happens that that
part of the country is low yeah but
there's lots of nice people like maybe
you live in a cheap area but there's
nice people and it does nothing I am a
lot of people slaves of some reason it
come from Barnsley I've always I've
always loved it I've always made it what
I want to make you there's good and bad
people everywhere you could go to London
there's some lots of London well yeah
well it cost five point five hundred
grams half a million to buy a one bit
apartment complete shabby disgusting
looking there a garage in London I think
about 150,000 yeah a small tire yeah and
possibly it will be discussed I think
there's good in those bad areas and
there's good and there's bad people in
every area buy a car it's just a
literally a return on investment thing
yeah tell me some of the big things the
big takeaways that you got from the
crash course I just found it really
really inspiring obviously you're going
to a lot more detail not move to what
you aches I want people to come on your
cars and you're in so much detail you
learn so much if then strategy is how to
find like I say sweet spot if it meals
how to work out the return on investment
rather then see if you've got some money
in the bank what you you get in the bank
fine I think my business banker get
point 10% you know it's bad where it
starts with zero yeah yeah my temper
said it's pointless yeah a lot of people
I've found a very risk-averse
yeah not take any race I'll do this I'll
I'll work till I'm 16 that tire
then pour money in the bank although you
could say it's not whiskey even though
it actually is yeah but you know what's
gonna happen but what's going to happen
sucks yeah so it's like oh I'd rather be
certain that I'm going to be broke
forever then have some risk that likes
it very easily be really successful it's
kind of like a path a certainty
mentality now as you're someone who's an
entrepreneur on any of several
businesses you run a you're a wedding
singer well we can be friends sings I
play guitar the wedding the wedding
singer the Miller callers we're not
going up car anyway okay oh yeah so
you've got a wedding singing business
yeah you've also got a luck out what
tent a tepee business et obviously with
the contacts of made in the wedding
industry we go to that many weddings
hundred and fifty last year weddings and
games easier and we see different things
coming in so rather than the box and the
marquee but these TPS which would use an
amazing we're running next craft cars in
them maybe well I've said no I said
could we do it could be yeah so talk to
me about your entrepreneur yeah you've
got businesses you do well and that's
did you pop the money that you're
putting down to deposits on properties
is coming from a comp well it's coming
for your business yeah but then you're
also refinancing the houses as I know up
and recycling getting everything about
that people are watching this who might
be very risk-averse and they're putting
money in a bank and they're got a job
and all this what's it like living on
the edge or do you live on the edge I
don't anybody when I started I mean just
sucks I mean some people not tonight
though it's alright for these two have
got their own business that the house
have got some money on the side I when I
was 13 when out cleaning cars I want to
buy a guitar and my mom said I don't
wanna get your tech detox your cousin's
got one he's never played at etc and how
really want a guitar so maybe friend
went out cleaning cars so everybody got
a guitar yeah from then my always work
saved money all my businesses financed
myself not never really put mine in 2000
then how come to TV business to chat to
be bit more and it your service from
there yeah and then but if you if you're
risk averse if you're gonna keep the
money in your van you're not gonna get a
return yeah but do you think the great
story by the way and I think most people
that are I met that are millionaires or
even just successful financially free
most of them have got that even as a kid
yeah there's just there's just I don't
know why there's just some fire inside
my belly and I just even now finally I
can't wait to get back to work
yeah do you think having a job
potentially is more risky than being
self-employed definitely and I totally
appreciate that it must be a big dive a
big jump going from a secure job to mean
South employees yeah and it's not for
everyone I understand that but the best
thing I've ever done I'm sure it's best
thing you've ever done becoming
self-employed then you just when the
dark hour when you see the opportunities
you just think I'm not working for this
person for so much come on yeah well I
could just do all this yourself
yeah if you love your job great stuff
because the thing is if you've got a job
too if the economy changes and you've
got a job you can very easily lose your
job and and and having a good job for
life doesn't exist any well no that's
sir and myself coming from a deep music
production at you in it you don't just
walk into a steward and say oh I play
guitar you can get a job
yeah the market I saw tough yeah I guess
that somewhere laughter I need to make
this myself
yeah so I bought a recording studio
after unit develop that I've sold that
on now yeah
even when I had my recording studio oh I
will busy on the weekend so I can record
I said some of my friends will record it
you can Ashley studio go out and find
your own work and just pay me a little
higher fee yeah compliment yeah so the
thing is though whatever the economy
does you will always land on your feet
yeah because you're an entrepreneur
whatever the property market does you'll
adjust
oh yeah guards yeah so I love that so
much what words of advice would you get
as we begin to wrap up she's someone who
was maybe in a job or an entrepreneur
but someone that was really
wanting to get into property what advice
would you give to them well like you
said everyone always says it is educate
yourself read books audiobook you've
nothing to lose going into the crash
cast myself and my back that way she's
now stat she's got a property she's
getting another one go to the crash cars
see how he find it watching youtube
videos read large people's books the
more you can educate yourself the better
just like you say God have you financial
freedom challenge for example you've
lost it all
I'm sure fingers crossed in six weeks
matter all that makes you smart enough
yeah love that yeah I think that
property is the second best thing to
invest in the best is yourself oh
definitely
and I totally agree with that and all
the rest times when I thought all that
sounds a bit corny but then when you
think about it now I've got all the
knowledge and the skills yeah never
never gonna go yeah I could be brought
tomorrow and that's be able to with me
track record like yours make a success
yeah you know about business you know
about marketing you know finances yeah
so educate yourself yeah yeah that is
number one well Brett thank you so much
for reaching out to me on Facebook no
problem anymore
watching this video if they've got a
story like yours off the back of the
crash course yeah you will message with
you on Facebook will get you on this
seat in the meantime stay tuned god
bless see you next time my name is
Samuel Leeds thank you for watching
winners on a Wednesday every single week
we interview a success students for your
inspiration you can watch more right
here on the playlist as a whole playlist
of them so what you'll notice is every
single winner on a Wednesday always
starts with them coming to my two day
crash course so if you would like to be
a winner on a Wednesday literally come
on my crash course and who knows in
three months time you could be here in
my offices on this show as a winner on a
Wednesday so get yourself booked on the
crash course watch more have fun I'll
see you next week